ever since democrats came out swinging
against florida's parental rights in
education bill which bans sexual
conversations from kindergarten through
third grade classrooms the libs have
found themselves on the receiving end of
a new political slogan
okay groomer
some conservatives think this slogan is
hyperbolic and counterproductive i for
one think it's great
after years of democrats bandying about
the word racist unfairly to destroy
people's lives and shut down debate i am
all for a potentially equally powerful
word like groomer which in this case i
think is being used fairly
conservatives are arguing that if you
insist on having sexual conversations
with kids in the classroom or anywhere
else and then hiding those conversations
from their parents
you are a groomer you are priming kids
for certain kinds of sexual behaviors
for a certain kind of sexual perspective
the attack so far seems pretty effective
according to recent polls the vast
majority of likely voters support the
florida law and oppose sexual
conversations with little kids and yet
despite the popularity of this bill and
other bills
democrats are doubling down all the way
up to the white house which now says
it's going to fight to protect sexual
conversations between teachers and
little kids
in florida and all around the country
bad news for kids
bad news for the culture but potentially
bad news for democrats too as voters
head into the midterms pissed off and
eager to protect their kids i'm michael
nolsus the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from sunshine water
who says i didn't even know my teacher's
first names until i got my yearbooks
that's true this is true i loved my
teachers i still speak to a number of my
teachers including teachers all the way
back to my kindergarten teacher as a
matter of fact so i love my teachers we
have kept in touch
at least with many of those teachers
but we never had any of these kinds of
conversations when we were in the
classroom i agree i didn't didn't know
many of my teachers first names i
certainly didn't know what they were
doing on date night and that that all
seems to have changed now
i always want to be fair on this issue i
do not want to be a pyromaniac in a
field of straw men and so i have twisted
the arm of my friend jessica tarlov who
is one of if not my very favorite
democrat out there uh jessica you know
her from the five she's a host of the
five she's vice president of insights at
bustle she is the author of america in
the age of trump opportunities and
oppositions in an uncertain world if
trump runs for president again we might
get a second run of that book we might
get the age of trump part two
uh so jesse first of all thank you so
much for coming on the show i very much
appreciate it
so i have talked to a colleague of yours
ethan behrman about the substance of
this law in florida the parental rights
and education bill i'm i'd be more than
interested certainly in hearing your
take on the substance but first at least
i want to get to your thoughts as a
political strategist
the opposition to this bill and others
seems to be a total loser for democrats
in virginia in florida in every poll
i've seen on the subject
why are democrats doubling down
well you're right well first of all i
want to know if ethan beerman is
potentially your favorite democrat since
you said i was your favorite you rank so
much higher it's not even close he is
you can't even see him from where you
are on the list
well he's actually a lawyer which i am
not so he's probably good to speak to
about the substance of the bill in a
different way um than i am in terms of
this being a loser democrats have fared
very poorly with culture war issues as
of late obviously we had a good year in
2020 and was able to take back the
presidency
um and control of the senate which made
all the difference um but we do know
that that was obviously affected by the
fact that we were in the midst of a
global health pandemic and we had uh
trump who's a very particular type of
republican on the ballot i know you're a
fan but there are many republicans who
remain uncomfortable with his style um
in terms of
the don't say gay bill which i will
admit when i first heard about this i
then searched for the term don't say gay
in the bill because you would think that
it was in there it is not explicitly in
there it's part it's
it's a quirky slogan it's something that
people think will be catchy it has been
used in a lot of ads here and i think
it's very confusing for a lot of people
now i happen to think that the bill is
dangerous i don't think that there's a
need for it and i've seen a lot of
counter arguments against it
um
going back to first of all how often are
these conversations happening and i'm
sure that people would say well one time
is too many but we can't legislate for
an entire state or entire country based
upon outlier issues seen pushback from
teachers who have said that this means
that they can't talk about their lives
with their students and you may not have
known your teacher's first name or
whether they were married or if they had
kids but i went to school here in new
york city and i only called my teachers
by their first names i knew their entire
families who were active participants in
my school and i ended up just fine and i
have a new daughter and i'm not you know
she identifies as a girl because i said
that she identifies as a girl and she
even wears pink sometimes so i i really
don't think that this is nearly as
dangerous as an issue
as republicans would have it be
but i know it's all about politics all
the time and i believe that it is a
winning issue
for them now that we have parents that
are pissed off about crt and now they're
pissed off about
sexual indoctrination at the age of six
so uh to your point on
whether this is a real issue or not it
seems to me democrats are running into a
contradiction which is and they ran into
the same contradiction on crt which is
on the one hand they're saying it's not
happening crt is not being taught in the
classroom these conversations are not
happening in kindergarten it's not a big
deal at all but then on the flip side
they say
it's the end of the world if we ban
these conversations if we ban crt from
the classroom or if we ban
sexual conversations from kindergarten
so i'm noticing they're going back and
forth here and i'm not sure if there is
a consensus but if it's if the
conversations aren't happening then
great the law is no big deal it's more
wasted inc in government but hey we've
got a lot of that already so what so
then i come back to this political
question and and it seems you agree with
the political uh
outlook on how this is going to fare for
dems in the midterms so then what
happened are they just crazy have they
just lost their minds and they're
running with a bill that they one don't
think even matters all that much and two
is deeply unpopular with voters
well there's always an issue and it's on
both sides of the aisle between the
extremes right we had that obviously
when the tea party came to power right
the moderate republicans were looking at
them saying this is absolute madness and
we have an extreme left in in our party
right now and the people in the middle
of the moderates that are trying to win
races in virginia and michigan et cetera
are looking them and saying excuse me
could you please stop talking i don't
want here to [ __ ] the police i don't
want to hear about socialized medicine
we want to hear about middle of the road
solutions which is how joe biden won so
i think there's a bit of a communication
problem there because often the p the
most extreme people have the biggest
platforms they're the most effective on
social media they're kind of screaming
from the rooftops about this but there's
this fundamental problem going on right
now with my party about what we should
be focused on and voters have been clear
they care about inflation and the cost
of living that's it that's really all
they care about we would like to save
ukraine from putin sure
we think afghanistan was bungled
sure but we're happy to be out of the
war etc climate change still a really
big deal but not as big of a deal as
whatever it is a 22
rise in the cost of beef at your average
supermarket so that's what the midterms
is going to be about and the moderate
wing of the party certainly understands
that
the left-wing side of the party i think
is a running in districts that are
probably too safe for their own good and
b just doesn't want to say that they're
listening to polls and that is as
someone who was a former former
political poster now does it for
consumer brands i can tell you that's
where everything's won that's where the
dollars are won that's where the
elections are won and the moderate wing
of the party
is message testing all of that they're
listening to their focus groups and
they're saying this is just a loser for
us
and there's too much time to be having
this conversation
that it can go on and on and on and
actually allow republicans to be focused
on these culture war issues which they
have been winning as of late rather than
having to put up their own plans and i
brought this up on the five yesterday
for instance on the health care issue
mitch mcconnell was on a sunday show
last weekend and was asked about well
what's the republican plan so that's a
really good issue i'll get a really good
question i'll get back to you
republicans may very well well win on
the health care issue but they haven't
put forward a plan but with democrats
screaming about these other ancillary
things it won't make a difference
necessarily at the polls and that's
where my frustration with it lies and to
your point about if these conversations
aren't happening i didn't say they
weren't happening at all i'm but i do
remain fundamentally concerned about the
young kid a six seven year old and there
are a lot of people who are gay straight
grow up to be trans etc who say that
they knew that
sorry i shouldn't have said gay straight
who are gay who feel that they knew that
when they were really young and if they
don't feel like they can talk to their
parents about it why shouldn't they be
able to go to their teachers to have
those conversations and i'm not saying
that parents should be left out of the
loop but if you are someone who believes
that you are born in the wrong body and
they've reported kids as young as four
years old who are saying that or saying
mommy i don't think i'm a girl i think
that i'm a boy
and if they can't say that to their
mommy they need someone who can help
them who they can go to and talk to
about that not to get on puberty
blockers but to have an open
conversation
well okay because that because that's an
important distinction i think my
response if a child came to if my own
child came to me and said i think i'm a
girl even though i'm a boy i i would
tell him as lovingly as gently as i
possibly could i'd say well you're not
you're not a girl you're you might you
might have a psychological condition you
might have seen something on the news
you might just be a little kid who gets
confused about things if it were a
little girl i might say you might just
be a tomboy i'm not denying your
feelings but you'll grow out of it as
most people do and but i would lovingly
try to deal with that and so what you're
saying is kids need a resource if
they've got awful terrible regressive
parents but not to the point to put them
on puberty blockers i think the fear
here is and we're seeing stories all
around the country of this
kids before puberty by definition are
being put on these kinds of drugs there
was a whistleblower just came out of
school nurse who said 11 year olds are
being put on these kinds of drugs
without their parents notification and
so it it does raise this i mean i guess
this is where you get the actual title
of the florida bill parental rights and
education
whose right is if you've got two
fundamentally different world views the
traditional world view
that says boys if you've got a boy's
body then you're a boy and you can't be
a girl secretly they just deny the whole
premise of transgenderism and the new
sort of secular transgender view which
says no your body and your
true self can be totally different you
should deny the body and go on puberty
blockers and whatever else is going to
be
following that well who wins out who
wins i people might think the old
christian view or jewish view or
traditional view is is regressive and
terrible and harmful though by the way
the studies i don't think really back
this up on the efficacy of puberty
blockers at reducing suicidality or
depression but but let's put that aside
for a second
who gets to choose is it is it the
parents if the who let's say they even
deny transgenderism let's say they even
look on homosexuality with moral
appropriate their orthodox jews their
traditional christians whatever
or the teachers who are the
representatives of this new secular
culture
well i think fundamentally that parents
should be responsible for these types of
decisions with their children but even
the example that you talked about the
case of the 11 year old who was put on
puberty blockers um and the school knew
and the parents didn't know that's an 11
year old and this bill is talking about
five-year-olds through third grade so
that's
right five through eight-year-olds
well that's good yeah they certainly
shouldn't be put on the puberty blockers
and they can't be legally put on puberty
blockers but i'm just saying that we're
not actually that's an extension of this
that is totally separate from that bill
and i think that that's part of the
problem
when
we talk this fast and loose about things
like this and so few people actually
read the substance of these bills and
they're just railing about well i heard
this and i heard that instead of getting
getting down to the nitty-gritty of
what's in there so we were talking about
extremely young kids you're not denying
the fact that children you said even my
children could potentially feel this way
and express a concern about their gender
identity but when you said that you
would lovingly say this to them
i could push back easily and say it's
not actually loving of a child who's
coming to you and telling you that
they're struggling with their gender
identity to tell them well it's just not
true
and yeah a little girl like it's fine if
you want to be a tomboy but you're not a
boy
because unless you fundamentally refute
the possibility that transgenderism
exists and
i fundamentally refute it i think it's a
complete fantasy i think it's uh not to
get too down the weeds but i think it's
just a new version of the old gnostic
heresy that says that our bodies and our
souls and really when we're talking
about transgenderism we don't like to
use these theological terms but that's
what we're talking about we're saying my
physical self is totally different from
my metaphysical self and the physical
self should be denied and the
metaphysical self that i at least
imagine should bring the physical body
more in line with what it perceives
itself to be
i think it's just bogus i think it's an
old crazy religious heresy i think it's
harmful to everyone who's involved in it
and i think it should be discouraged and
i think when you go from point zero zero
one percent of people identifying as
transgender to now twenty point eight
percent of gen z identifying as
transsexual or pansexual or some other
gender identity issue
clearly that either alex jones is right
and there's something in the water or or
this is a social phenomenon that's going
on that that is related to how we're
even talking about these things
well alex jones is not right about
anything so
he was right about the frogs he was
right about the frogs yale proved it
i don't even know what you're talking
about but i cannot go along with it and
i try to block out as much alex jones
anything as possible um
so i do think that
social constructs certainly plays a role
in what's going on in the rise of people
identifying as gay as queer non-binary
transgender etc but
i would posit as well that we are at a
different time culturally where people
are feeling like they can actually speak
honestly and openly about who they are
and not feel like they're going to lose
their jobs not feel like they're going
to be ostracized from society there's
obviously been a huge evolution in terms
of how we treat people
who identify in these ways
and there are a lot of psychiatrists and
you're a lot of things but i don't
believe that you're a psychiatrist i'm
more of a biologist myself katanji
jackson is not but i consider myself
more of a biologist
well as a woman
i can tell you
that
there are plenty of psychiatrists out
there that believe strongly that
transgenderism is something that is real
it's something that also that if it
doesn't get addressed is going to lead
to tremendous spikes and we've seen this
in terms of suicide and self-harm and
depression and i go back to the original
north carolina bathroom bill which
basically came down to who cares
really who cares what some if you want
to the left cares
no no no
it was because the right had a problem
with people who identified as the other
gender using that bathroom right yeah
that's the change though right
but isn't that the change previously the
men who
identify as women were not allowed in
the women's bathroom the libs wanted
them to be able to use the women's
bathroom and the right said no but we're
not the ones who change the rules right
no but it was because republicans
made up an issue they said that these
people were identifying that men who
were identifying as women were going to
go into bathrooms and hurt people
yeah they were then it was just
disordered for them to go in
and that's a huge problem and such a
misrepresentation of the way that
transgender people live and if you
obviously i i have plenty to say about
leah thomas and i played sports up to
the collegiate level
not certainly at the d1 level the d3
level but i i understand that that is a
rich debate that is
very textured
but
to deny transgenderism when so many
people have studied this for their whole
lives and so many people who live this
life have said that they are happier
more effective have better relationships
but i would tell you jesse the the you
know one sometimes they say the plural
of anecdote is not data though frankly i
think it is right the plural of anecdote
actually is data but i've talked to
multiple people who had gender confusion
who even went through the process went
on testosterone started transitioning
and who deeply regretted it i've
probably talked to half a dozen people
who deeply deeply regretted it and wish
that someone told them the truth and
when we talk about who's a psychiatrist
or who's a biologist or i mean really
what we're talking about is who's a
philosopher and who's a theologian and
who's who's talking about this question
that you're bringing up too which is who
are we what is what is our true identity
is our true identity what we perceive it
to be does it have to do with the body
does it have to do with what my teachers
tell me in kindergarten we have to leave
it there because i'm seven minutes over
but you
though
though you may be
you may not be a biologist you may not
be a psychologist you might you may very
well be a philosopher you you do remain
among my top three favorite democrats
and i very much appreciate you coming on
where can people find you
well on fox a lot um on twitter at
jessica tarla but i try not to read my
mentions because i work at fox um
so twitter
basically
wonderful you can find jessica on
twitter find her on fox and i hope find
you back on this show very soon
thanks so much michael all right thanks
so much for coming on
now when you want to
uh protect the sort of things you're
looking for you know you're look you're
googling what is a man what is a woman
you know really controversial stuff like
that you've got to check out
expressvpn right now go to
expressvpn.com
knowles we know that big tech doesn't
like us we know that they target us for
our views so why are you letting them
peek in and look at everything you're
looking at on the internet every even
when you use that special super secret
incognito window
you're not hiding your data from these
big tech companies i'm talking about
when you're looking at websites that you
shouldn't be looking at recording you
know what i'm talking about those
websites that could get you in trouble
you know i'm talking about
dailywire.com you know what i mean you
don't want big tech knowing about that
that's probably the worst thing you
could be looking at
especially in a day when when people are
really being persecuted for their
political views expressvpn anonymizes
your online activity camouflages your ip
address replaces it with a different
secure ip of your choice i don't go on
without it i've got it on all my devices
i love it it's the number one rated vpn
provider go to expressvpn.com
knowles get three months for free on a
one year package exp or
essvpn.com
expressvpn.com head on over there to
check out the vpn that i trust
i love the ok groomer political
messaging and and my friend jessica here
has convinced me that it's the way to go
because republicans are winning on that
issue
i'm really i'm glad that we could get
into the substance because
you know we're talking about the issue
itself who are we what's transgenderism
what's what are are five can
five-year-olds be transgender can anyone
be transgender i like that
but she started out
at the political level what does this
mean in the midterms
and i think
it's clear as day to me
that this is a huge winner for
conservatives
when voters see
people talking about transitioning
children it just turns them off there
was some lunatic mother who went on abc
news the other day and talked about how
from her daughter's
very first
words
she began to identify
as a girl she was a it was a boy but
then identified as a girl
when chazzie our daughter when she
really started to
communicate to us and that was at the
earliest moment that she actually had
words and language um to communicate to
us who she truly was um we were a little
surprised because we didn't expect it
and then
as we just
literally
raised her
supported her just like all parents do
raising you know we're teaching her the
right values we're teaching her to give
back
you know one of her favorite things in
the world to do is to volunteer and be
in service to others you know that
surprise
evolves into something just really
cool and important and and that is the
realization that she's our daughter
that's the realization she had af when
she started saying
we just knew we just if anyone who's
ever had a child knows that this is
preposterous first of all it's it's
preposterous because your kids first
words are like you know doggy right your
kids first words don't even sound like
words they're just kind of sounds and so
this woman is
projecting something i don't know what
she's projecting and then it's so sad
because she shows photos of her son who
she's dressed up as a little girl and
it's obviously he's he's a boy he's a
boy it's obviously a boy and i i think
the the pictures here are the key to it
because you hear these
lunatic women like this this person here
men and women but this woman in
particular and she says my my
eight-month-old baby obviously was
transgender and you say this woman's
offer rocker and she's saying the same
kinds of things that elected democrats
are saying she's saying the same kinds
of things that the white house is
pushing right now and then you see it
you see it's so clear you see it in what
your kids being taught which became very
clear during covet when kids were being
taught online you see it when you look
at the picture and you say no the boy
actually isn't a girl and the girl
actually isn't a boy and we're careening
toward the midterms right now and this
is not going to go very well for
democrats
there's a teacher in kansas
uh who is insisted he's kindergarten
teacher in kansas who is insistent
that kindergarteners
are ready to learn about transgenderism
when they've been exposed to information
they're ready to learn about it whether
you think they are not
and the research says that there is no
age too young to talk about pretty much
anything if they know about it
they're ready to learn about
right so there is no
you know what we think is always
age-appropriate it is if they don't know
about it
if they haven't been exposed to it then
yeah you can give them time to develop
but once they're exposed to it and
social media is going to do it right i
know some kindergarteners in this school
with cell phones
mine had a cell phone
and so
they they get access to information they
can they can learn quickly the world is
teaching them faster than probably you
are they're students as early as
kindergarten who are identifying
um as uh
non-gender conforming uh non-binary
um
that are
transgender
and so because they're in our school
they're in our classrooms
then that becomes a responsibility on
the adults to say okay
um
i have a student who identifies this way
and so it's my responsibility to make
sure the classroom invite is inviting to
to them uh just like it is to someone
who might be um asian laotian um korean
um african um whatever the identity is
yeah so this five-year-old he's african
and so we're going to affirm that he's
african and this five-year-old says that
he's a unicorn and so we're going to
affirm that he's a unicorn right
which is just as coherent as saying that
the
little boy identifies as a little girl
there's a difference here of course
because there are such things as
africans there are such things as asians
there are your your race is something
that i can look at and say okay that's
real
just like your sex
is something that i can look at and say
that's real but your imagined identity
that is not real that's fake and that
shouldn't be affirmed the point he's
making here is so subtle and it's so
dangerous he's saying look i don't want
i don't want to teach kindergarteners
about
transgenderism i don't i don't want them
to learn about transgenderism but once
they find out about it then we have to
talk about it then they've cuddled
they're already
they're already hearing about it from
social media from their cell phones that
the five-year-olds have from the
smartphones that five-year-olds are
being given and he says i gave my own
five-year-old a cell phone right that
was a mistake that was bad parenting you
shouldn't do that
you that was that was your first mistake
now you're going to compound that first
mistake you're going to use that mistake
you're saying look i'm exposing my kids
to all this kind of transgender insanity
so now we've got to talk about it well
we wouldn't have to talk about it if you
weren't
exposing them to that in the first place
so it's a way of subtly getting that in
there and then he goes even more wrong
where he says and once it comes up then
i've got to affirm their transgenderism
no you don't you should deny it because
it's not real
it's just not real it's just made up i
don't want to sound cruel or insensitive
i actually think i'm being quite
compassionate and sensitive here when i
tell you i would tell a five-year-old
and i'd certainly tell his kindergarten
teacher it's just not
real
yeah i'm sure the experience of it is
real a feeling of it's real but it is
not because a boy actually can't be a
girl
and this is the radicalism you're seeing
you're and you're going to see this from
just about every teacher well it comes
up in the classroom sure it comes up in
the classroom and you're totally right
you do probably have a responsibility to
address something that comes up in the
classroom
so how are you going to address it well
one of two ways
one of three ways i guess one is you
shut it down and you say talk to your
parents
two
you say
no johnny boys can't be girls or three
you say yes johnny boys can be girls
you are teaching something this is why
it's not enough for conservatives to
just say get the politics out of the
classroom
the politics are gonna be in the
classroom politics just means public
stuff it just means the stuff that
people are talking about the way that we
live our lives that's gonna end up in
the classroom it's not enough to say
hands off don't talk about it you
actually have to have a point of view as
i say in my book speechless free speech
doesn't mean anything to people who
don't have anything to say so it's not
enough these laws are a good start to
say you can't preach transgenderism in
kindergarten they should go further
you should teach an affirmative
accurate
true
understanding of human nature
you should say boys or boys and girls or
girls
and when when a man and a woman love
each other very much they leave their
families and they get married and when
they get married because the sexes are
complementary they have children and
they reproduce and that's a good thing
actually that they do that and that's
how we all got here and you do that at
age appropriate times but you don't you
can't just bury your head in the sand
and you can't just avoid
reality
i want to talk about what's going on
with kids right now
the most horrifying story i probably
i've ever seen in the news we've been
talking about it for a couple days this
live action
story about how
in dc
there were five babies who were killed
through abortion and now a whistleblower
brought these bodies that were
photographs taken a pro-life activist
broke the story
and and so the authorities are of course
investigating the pro-lifers they're
letting the abortions off the hook
they're investigating the pro-lifers
it's not just five babies by the way
this has happened
well over a hundred times
and they've only got evidence of the
five they've only got physical evidence
of the five well turns out live action
has a clip of the abortionist this
butcher who committed these atrocities
and
uh
this goes back years now and he admitted
that he was allowing in violation of the
law allowing babies who were born alive
simply to die take a listen
obviously you're here for a certain
procedure and if your your pregnancy
were let's say you went into labor the
membranes ruptured and you delivered
before we got to the termination part of
the procedure here you know then we
would do things we would we would not
help her
we wouldn't we wouldn't uh intubate okay
okay so you would make sure yeah we
wouldn't do any extra you know it's like
uh yeah it would be you know uh a person
that would be a terminal person in the
in in the hospital say they had cancer
you know you wouldn't do any extra
procedures to help that person survive
they had like do not resuscitate orders
okay you know we would do the same
things here okay whereas if you were in
in a hospital in in virginia let's say
and you went into labor and you went to
the hospital and then they saw you
deliver they would do everything
possible to help that peter survive okay
but you won't we wouldn't
yeah we wouldn't do it you know the
thing that all the hospitals do because
that's the law we don't do that here
you know how they help the fetus survive
even if you're going to use a silly word
like fetus instead of baby people say
fetus because they don't want to admit
that a baby in the womb is a baby
the fetus quote unquote stops being a
fetus by any definition once he's out of
the womb so then what he's saying is we
wouldn't help the fetus survive he's
saying we wouldn't help the baby survive
so do that here he talks about all this
poor woman she went to the hospital once
because her abortion didn't work out for
her and then she gave birth to the baby
and they wouldn't let her kill the baby
this guy this guy how many times has he
done this
it's it
it's almost funny if not for the
incredible suffering involved it would
almost be funny how ghoulish this guy
sounds his name is dr cesare santangelo
you probably haven't even heard that
name dr cesare santangelo
this guy we talk about vladimir putin
vladimir putin's a butcher he's
committing war crimes sure we talk about
people like bashar assad the dictator in
syria he's a butcher he's committed war
crimes sure
cesare santangelo is is just as bad
probably worse because he's focusing all
of it on innocent little babies that's
his job that's how he makes his money in
violation of the law he seems to know it
stone cold psychopath the guy should at
the very least be locked up for the rest
of his life frankly i would recommend a
harsher punishment from the civil
authority than that and this name this
name no one even knows his name you
should be posting this name you should
be publicizing this name cesare
santangelo
the worst killer the worst serial killer
murderer
in this country right now
who knows who knows how many victims
he's got maybe the worst in american
history
shine a light on that there are all of
the entrenched powers are trying to
cover it up cover up for this psycho and
trying to to bury the bodies actually
trying to incinerate the bodies without
even doing an autopsy don't let him get
away with it you know
you know
sometimes on this show i have to say i
told you so sometimes that's happy with
good political predictions sometimes
it's sad with bad political predictions
but i was still correct well
all of my prophecies that have come to
light have inspired a new collection of
merchandise over at dailywire.com
shop this is the nostradamus line that's
right that's right you all know that the
difference between a conspiracy theory
and the truth is six months these days i
have this wonderful new merch and i see
it i foresee it in your future go to
dailywire.com shop today order from the
nolstradamus line we'll be right back
with a lot more
the democrats are so upset about this
okay groomer slogan the fact that
republicans are accurately criticizing
them for having insisting on having
sexual conversations with little kids
without their parents knowing about it
they're so upset that they're trying to
throw that punch back on republicans and
it's not working and it's extremely
dishonest the way they're doing it at
tennessee my my state was trending
yesterday on social media and it was
trending because of a bill senate bill
562 house bill 233
uh brought brought forward by
representative leatherwood
which would redefine certain aspects of
marriage in tennessee and the headline
according to all the media
was
tennessee republicans want to get rid of
age limits for marriage
tennessee republicans
take out an age limit in a marriage
statute so they can cover up for child
abuse and have child brides and their
pedos and they're they're the real
groomers that was the headline and i saw
that headline and i said no that's not
true
i didn't know anything about the story i
hadn't read the bill i said that's just
obviously not true
so you can read the bill's two pages
long it's not that hard and it's mostly
just kind of boring
government gobbledygook but it changes
it changes a little bit the definition
of marriage and what it appears to do
just from my first reading is it gives a
protection
to public officials
who do not believe that marriage can
exist between two men or two women who
adhere to the definition of marriage
that has existed everywhere throughout
all of human history until five minutes
ago and who feel that it would be a
violation of their conscience and
and their religious beliefs if not
reality outright to
participate in in such unions
that's what it's about the
representative who brought it said quote
all this bill does is give an
alternative form of marriage for those
pastors and other individuals who have a
conscientious objection to the current
pathway to marriage in our law tom
leatherwood quoted by wkrn
the it doesn't even get rid of
gay marriage or the redefinition of
marriage that we got from the supreme
court through the obergefell decision it
just
clarifies marriage and gives a specific
category a specific carve out to the
definition of marriage we've had for all
of human history everywhere in the world
so what happened with the age
requirements well i knew it the second i
heard about this obviously
the state reps just messed up the
language a little bit
obviously as they were mending a statute
they just they accidentally left out one
part or didn't include but
no no one in their right mind would ever
propose a bill to say that you should be
able to marry a five-year-old that's
just no one no one did it no matter how
poorly the left wing thinks of us how
evil the left wing thinks that we are
how stupid the left wing thinks we are
no one would do that because it's not
right and it's politically just
completely idiotic even if some psycho
thought that it's a good idea to be able
to marry five-year-olds he still
wouldn't put it forward because it's a
total political loser and there's no
evidence whatsoever that the people who
propose this bill ever suggested
anything like that in fact there's a lot
of evidence to the contrary
in march in a committee hearing in march
the representative leatherwood who put
this forward said
that that
as he understood the very legislation
that it would quote not allow minors
children under the age of 18 who haven't
even reached the age of consent to enter
into a marriage contract so it's just
it's just a completely made-up issue
it's a total non-traversing but the fact
that the democrats are focusing on this
completely made-up part of the bill
tells you two things one they're really
sensitive about the groomer line
one it's they're very vulnerable on this
groomer issue that they're being accused
of weird sex stuff with kids and now the
fact that they're supreme court nominees
most glaring part of her judicial record
is that she lets pedos off the hook that
certainly doesn't help so they're very
sensitive about that it's a good area
that republicans should keep pushing on
but two
it's that they don't want to talk about
the real issue of the bill the real
issue of the bill and maybe you agree
with it maybe you don't is that the
people pushing it do not believe that
the obergefell decision was legit they
do not believe that there is any such
thing as gay marriage same-sex marriage
no slight to gay people no slight to
people with differing or eccentric
sexual desires but they just believe
marriage is marriage it actually has a
meaning you can't change the meaning you
can't completely upend it and so they're
trying to give a carve out for people
who still believe that maybe you support
that maybe you oppose that but one thing
i know for sure is that the democrats
don't want to deal with that issue on
just like they didn't want to deal with
the redefinition of head-on period the
redefinition of marriage had on period
when it was put up
for a vote
do you want to change the definition of
marriage to include monogamous same-sex
couples for now they'll probably change
it
again when it was put up to a vote it
failed
when it was put up to a vote in super
duper liberal california it failed
proposition 8.
then nine robed judges on the court
decided to just rewrite the constitution
and invent this right anthony kennedy
the romantic poet on the supreme court
just invented a new definition of
marriage completely
out of nowhere
and the democrats who insist that this
is very popular and it's a wonderful
thing to do they don't want to defend
that
and so they make up a bunch of nonsense
that's not in the bill
by the way the lawmakers already filed
an amendment
to clarify that minors are not allowed
to do this
you have to reach the age of majority to
do it
completely made up but i think the
democrats are actually telling on
themselves and they're telling
republicans how to fight this political
battle come november
now
joe biden
is uh
focusing on the anything he can to try
to win back
november to try to stem the title waves
that he's gonna have to deal with in
november he's losing on the economy he's
losing on jobs he's losing on foreign
policy he's losing on covet he's losing
on the weird creepy sex stuff with the
kids he's losing losing losing losing
so
the the one hail mary is trying to throw
here
is to pause
payments on student loans
the biden administration just announced
that he is ex they are extending the
federal student loan payment pause they
are going to move the return of student
debt repayment from may 1st of this year
to august 31st they had already paused
it in december of last year
no
serious economist thinks this is a good
idea forget conservatives for a second
even larry summers former president of
harvard former top economist to barack
obama when joe biden was vice president
said this is nuts he said it's very hard
to understand this in policy terms this
is not a small macroeconomic thing at a
time when the economy is overheating
student debt action will be injecting
money into the economy at a 100 billion
a year annual rate this is a
macroeconomic step in the wrong
direction so to put that into layman's
terms what he's saying is
right now we're dealing with
inflation inflation is going through the
roof there's just too much money
swirling around right now and so what
joe biden is and a lot of that is caused
by not just biden's policy of this but
years and years and years of just
printing money and giving away money and
so the money is not as valuable and
things cost a lot more and what this
biden policy does rather than trying to
pull that back trying to get a hold on
inflation it's going to inject another
100 billion dollars a year into the
economy of just free money that the
students or the graduates now are not
paying
for no reason whatsoever these college
graduates by and large are doing better
economically than people who don't have
a college degree their degree might not
be worth what they paid for it's
probably not worth a quarter of a
million dollars to go study lesbian
dance theory or whatever else we're
talking frankly even to get a regular
old degree from an ordinary academic
program these days it's not as valuable
because people aren't being taught as
much and and the the practical value of
the university education is not what it
once was but regardless they're still
doing better these are still wealthier
americans these are still the
upper-class americans who are now being
bailed out by everyone else that's not
fair
that's not fair at all so but it does
this does make sense of it
i now get from a policy perspective why
joe biden's doing this larry summers
might not get it
because economically it doesn't make
sense but politically it makes a lot of
sense one
it's a de facto federal takeover of
education the the democrats are having a
hard time selling free college they're
having a hard time selling it because
it's just a handout to the upper classes
in america
most people in america don't graduate
from a four-year college i think it's
what one in four americans graduates
from a four-year college
and then they go on and make more money
and and have a more economically
prosperous life so why are the why are
the lower classes going to going to be
paying extra money to the upper classes
because the upper class has made a poor
financial decision it can't pay back the
debt on their college degrees doesn't
make a lot it's not a big seller it's
not going to play very well in peoria so
the democrats are having a hard time
doing that
so what they're doing is just saying
okay we're going to pause it we're just
going to pause it and run out the clock
and the more the government is involved
in education in this way
the more influence they're going to have
over the educational system he who pays
the piper calls the tune that's the
first first part second part is it's
payoff to biden supporters college
graduates
people who have spent four years maybe
not learning a whole lot of the
classical tradition or the liberal arts
but definitely learning a lot of leftist
ideology they're more likely to vote for
democrats and so
it's a payoff it's a payoff to the
people who are more likely to vote for
democrats and it's an incentive to other
people to go and get these degrees
knowing that very likely they're not
going to have to pay them back anyway
and the democrats know that if kids go
to college and spend four years getting
indoctrinated in this crap they're more
likely to vote for them
free money it's a it's a way
to
ensconce yourself in power as long as
the money doesn't run out a california
city is doing this right now palm
springs in california is testing out a
policy
to just give people money for calling
themselves transgender
to just give them money to give them a
payment of nine 900 per month
only if they identify as transgender or
non-binary which donate those things
don't exist but if you identify that way
you get the free money from palm springs
i could go to palm springs i say hey i
want my free money they say are you
transgender i say no they don't give it
to me
but then if i came back maybe i put a
little mustache on or groucho glasses i
said hey it's me again yeah i'm
transgender now
i say okay here's your money you have to
meet a certain
poverty threshold but it's specifically
for transgenderism
why
why are they doing this
the only conclusion you can draw is that
they want more people to identify as
transgender
that's it you don't need to be larry
summers you don't need to be one of the
top economists in the country to know
that when you incentivize something you
get more of it that's why you
incentivize it
and the left is incentivizing this they
are
grooming kids
they're doing it
i don't think they're doing it primarily
because they want to diddle kids or
something like that maybe i don't know
maybe but i actually don't i don't
think that's the primary motivation i
think it's because they want kids to
believe in their political ideology and
their political ideology is one of
liberation liberation from oppressive
systems liberation from custom and
tradition from the past which is also
awful liberation from human nature
itself
some of the people pushing this are
cynical politicians but some of them i
think are true believers
and they know this is why they focused
on education so long they know
that if you can get kids when they're
really really young
that you're going to be able to mold
their brains the classroom is a crystal
ball for your country in 20 years and
they know that sex is one of if not the
primary driver in human nature it's not
the top top but it's pretty important
and so if a five-year-old
if a three-year-old if a one and a half
year old like that lunatic mother said
on tv
is
inculcated in this transgenderism
that's just going to be part of how they
view the world
if you really think about how important
that is think about how important your
religious foundation is for those of you
who grew up with religion
it colors the way you see the entire
world
and the left wants more of this
and there are many
there are many reasons why they want
more of this part of i mean the most
basic reason we should do a whole
episode on all of the reasons but the
most basic reason is for the left the
family has always been the greatest
impediment to their political takeover
they have to
turn people into radical atomized
individuals in order to gain power in
order to push their ideological agenda
of radical liberation and in order to to
gain much more government power in order
to control your lives much more and take
away your freedom and take away your way
of life so this is one way to do it how
how better to break up the family than
to break up the basis of the family
which is sexual difference
it's been effective for the left in
conquering the culture there's just one
little impediment to them
and that would be the voters and the
voters hate this stuff
and the voters i hope come out and give
them a real shellacking in november
because the fight is not over it's just
beginning i'm michael knowles is the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2022.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire where we bring you all
the news that you need to know in 15
minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire